foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
Chris does when he puts the time on he
goes like this
so [ __ ] but that's the sh it is we've
talked about this before so it's kind of
the both wasn't sure what shirt I should
wear wore this wanted to wear this one
at only this one but it's a little bit
chilly so I put this one on you lose
that you look like you just went through
wardrobe on a show about high schoolers
[Laughter]
you do
what look at you look you're just like
Weird Al on vacation
uh no you gave me this
sound me I did give it to you I have so
many tie-dye things but this is the best
one and you forgot it myself too dude
let's talk about this guys Brea
California I'll be there tonight uh
Portland Oregon Seattle Washington I got
one show sold out the other one is uh
January 22nd Lakeland Florida Daytona
Beach oh it's so small thank you very
much Jacksonville Florida is small dude
oh wow
I just added Milwaukee I just added Salt
Lake City so get your tickets get the
good seats Chicago Sugar Land Austin
[ __ ] Columbus Texas Boise Boise Salt
Lake City uh so that's what's up that's
what we're doing with the uh with the
tour the Don't Push Me Tour go get your
ticket to chrysalia.com chrisley.com
thank you very much and if you want to
talk to me Mano Amano
man-to-man woman to man
uh one-on-one if you know what I'm
saying go to mattelia.com and book your
session with me
had some really sort of Wet and Wild
Ones this last week it was crazy hey I'm
at a water park what do I do
some very personal stuff that I was uh
able to help out with cool that's great
uh you want to go get the merch you go
to lifelinemerch.com we got new merch
coming so that's what's up we got to
talk about got to talk about that off
air uh and uh that's what's up like And
subscribe we're changing the name of the
channel because it's Shadow band
unbelievably because it has the word
it'll be changed by this comment okay so
welcome to super good we changed it just
very very minimally does that what we
change it to yep okay and you know that
so uh so it's all good we don't really
read texts from you so shitty
um so so what we're gonna do is we
changed it yep so that's it so like And
subscribe and we did it dude um was it
shadow man because it had the word
Colton for sure yeah that's really
stupid
um so here's the deal we uh it's been
absolutely a [ __ ] mess outside I
don't know where it is how it's been
when you where you live yeah it's been
terrible but the power went out been
terrible all across the country and
we're getting the ass end of it got it
so uh my power went out 9 A.M it just
goes like this
gone right I knew it was out because why
because the sound machine wasn't on
anymore and Kristen loves a sound
machine okay it just goes and I'll go
power's probably out looked power was
out so then you mean you figured it out
the way everyone in history has figured
it out oh no interesting I don't mean
that you know why because of how
because of how the the darkness it was
already the dark poetry it was the
darkness because we didn't have any
lights on dude because we didn't have
any lights on because we didn't wake up
yet because we don't wake up past nine
because Calvin sleeps till like 10 30.
yeah but I'm what I'm saying is everyone
figures out the power went off
when they realize a device that is
usually on is not my [ __ ] is like
how do you figure it out if all the
devices are off when the only device
that was on was the sound machine and it
wasn't like the sound it was like that's
how but it wasn't like there was a noise
that was being made it was like there
was no noise that was being made so I
did it in like a good way and like oh
wait a minute usually there's a sound
but now there's not a sound that's how
everyone figures out this the power's
off no dude if the power's off that's
how they figure it out so anyway I'm
just saying I did it with deductive
reasoning waking up knowing something
was off because I have the gift of fear
and I know what's up right okay I have
that woman's intuition and so which
woman
um so what I
so what I deduced was oh [ __ ] it's going
to be a day right guess what gate
wouldn't open cars were stuck inside but
also wasn't it already pouring there was
like we were in the middle of a cyclone
it was getting to that right so then
obviously you knew the power was out all
the more reason to know but also but
mostly it was the sound machine thing
but then also I heard yes there was a so
I go I go I look outside dude it wasn't
like [ __ ] uh the water was
coming down the street it was like a
river was coming down the street yeah
and it was unbelievable and I go like
this I'm [ __ ] I just like this we're
[ __ ] all day yeah depending upon where
you in La there's a lot of places you
can live if it rains like that
you're just you're basically out of
commission for at least a couple days
yeah you're stuck where you are because
the roads close and it's so like windy
and already to get to that if one of
those roads closes hundreds of people
are just totally screwed and also check
this out and also check this out they
don't
um everyone's like well it's good La
needed it dude La can take about four
inches of rain and then they the rest of
it it doesn't help LA because they don't
they don't have the irrigation system
all set up if they could figure out if
they when they built the city they've
when they built La in every phase
including up all the way up to roads and
highways yeah they built it as if it not
rains infrequently they built it as if
it never rains which is idiotic why
because every play it rains everywhere
at least sometimes it rains everywhere
at least sometimes so they actually
built the freeways like this instead of
everywhere else where you build them
like this I know because it's obvious so
the ring goes that way and you don't
slip and slide on the road it's getting
really hard to live in LA it's getting
really hard to want to stay in LA and
that's why I'm moving 30 minutes away to
[ __ ] cool La Canada cool More Bounce
to the Ounce
More Bounce to the Ounce nope what do
you mean why you even did that like Josh
Groban no you even did More Bounce to
the Ounce like Joshua flavor that I do
it dude yeah it's the Groban flavor more
about to the Ounce
dude you don't appreciate my style of
singing you're absolutely because we
grew up together dude no it's because
you're just used to it because it sucks
so many people hit me up about just do
singing videos no no one has just do
singing videos no one's ever done that
dude quit your day job just do singing
videos no
well we'll do that to me though for real
okay they put in requests so now you
know what they want me to do Pearl Jam
stuff no no Stone Temple Pilot stuff
so look it rained like a shitstorm I
mean it's still gonna be raining a
little bit but we're happy that it's
kind of done raining it did oh it is
done I don't think it's done I think it
might be done by the time this comes out
is what I'm saying by the time this
comes down it'll yes it'll actually have
just ended that's what I do because I'm
smart that was smart that was the first
time that was the first smart thing
you've ever done yeah tonight I'm not
gonna be I mean right it's because we're
filming it Wednesday but I know I'm
gonna be in Bray on Sunday so I say
tonight
you only did that better than me because
you're more used to doing podcasts
because you've been doing podcasts for
37 years that's not I have not been
doing podcasts since I was four hey guys
I'd like to talk about Legos what's up
with these new ones
um so uh yeah so anyway we're here I'm
glad you're here I'm glad I'm here we're
having a good time and so the power was
out Kristen and I and Calvin we
hightailed it to the [ __ ] into a hotel
and we stayed in a hotel okay and we had
a really [ __ ] honestly rip around
good time okay because Calvin loved
being in a hotel and it was really fun
dude and we got room survey and it was
what I was gonna do that too
is that a thing we do well it's I think
it's boom mommy mommy
right but why do we both want to do that
we have done that before okay a long
long time ago we used to go on vacation
together
and then what is it
because we the room service bangs on the
door I don't know if it's really bang my
door but anyway wow that's so Rusty
foreign
how on everybody's ass you are about how
they use salt
you're like that with me you're like
with somebody across the room while
you're recording it's like it's RoboCop
yeah what is a consult like them [ __ ]
so [ __ ] drop it
what is that
shoot the [ __ ] salt out but it goes
remember the [ __ ] in Robocop when he
shoot when he's like this and he shoots
the wall and it [ __ ] ricochets off
the guy that kills him like that do you
remember that no but that's cool yeah so
that is cool um RoboCop's great it is
great so but no but what was I saying
though I'm on people's ass because you
put salt on one way like this but so on
my way I'm like this you know how you
put the salt on you know how you put the
salt on and you know how it is it's very
trying to believe that I do wait hang on
it's so dainty
he goes like this
yeah man that's [ __ ] [ __ ] so you get it
out the right amount you're not just
like [ __ ] haphazard to the Ounce did
you don't do it haphazard like this
that's stupid you [ __ ] up your food no
when you have the Finesse when you have
the way to finesse that is finesse no
that's not funny like this it's not it's
jerky finessing it is this is jerky
jerky off
finessing it is like this dude I take
the salt I lay it in my hand I just lay
it like I don't even [ __ ] with it like I
just lay it it's not even like I'm
holding it and then I just [ __ ]
finesse it over the plate of pasta like
what's your other hand doing there
what is that it's balancing
you're not even holding it I'm holding
it like this I'm finessing it and I'm
keeping my my weight nice so I'm just
putting it on the salad like that I'm
putting it on like that and but by the
way I saw cookies I saw lots of [ __ ] you
saw I know what's up dude have you ever
put salt on chocolate chip cookies no
I've had salt on chocolate chip cookies
chocolate chip cookies a Mexican
folklore uh demon to cookies
okay hey go to sleep now before Jacob
that was just such like a brain uh uh
you know fart what what ideas
can you check for two cookies under my
bed yeah okay sure oh he's not there but
go to sleep I mean Mexicans don't talk
like that you know well yeah have you
seen trading day
they speak Spanish you know what you
know what Mexicans for real Listen to
More Than Anything yeah More Bounce no
to the outside
probably Francisco says the papa
Francisco thing no I'm sick Mexican but
I'm saying like Mexican like American
Mexicans dude they listen to the [ __ ]
Papa Francisco makes a joke about they
can be what's the joke it's you can be
as hard as you you can be the hardest
[ __ ] if you're Mexican but they
still listen to that same old music yeah
but anyway dude
um so anyway what were we talking about
right before that I lay it on like that
and I balance all my other hands that's
a [ __ ] it's not dude
if you're at a restaurant you see me
doing the salt you go like this oh [ __ ]
he's got it down I get no what else does
he know
um I would like to announce something
can I do that before we even get into
the show sure let me get comfortable
fall asleep
I am having another well no we are
having another baby
we're having another baby and it's a boy
how awesome is that I'm excited we're
excited thank you very much uh uh you
know for your support and all that we
can't wait to to uh to have this baby
boy do you
we have two things in uh mind one is
Firestorm one is Megatron
not Raiden
Raiden no and then we also have another
name Vin Diesel we might call Vin Diesel
delete that's good um I'm already M
diesel so Vin Diesel Dalia or Firestorm
Dalia okay um we do have some names
picked out yeah but we're not sure yet
well everyone who's about to have a baby
has some names picked up
if you noticed that's not what I asked I
asked if you have a name picked up we
have a name everyone has some names we
have a name picked out twice right on
two different occasions you have a name
yeah yeah yeah we like two names
so okay we'll see what happens dude well
congratulations thank you very much and
it's very good you obviously already
knew this I did
um not because I told him because you're
a clairvoyant and it was amazing no I'm
an OB GYN I could tell yep uh
um
all right so guys uh you know second
congratulations in the comments thank
you very much I appreciate that I'm sure
you're saying it so I appreciate all
your comments wow uh getting a little
ahead of yourself
so uh let's get it the way it does
question does Calvin know yeah he does
what does he say he knows he's gonna be
a big brother he was eating by himself
the other day he says I'm gonna be the
best Big Brother hmm eating just eating
pasta and then he says uh is the baby in
mama's belly
I mean he's pretty smart then he knows
yeah it's really smart it's pretty crazy
dude okay so we'll see how he how he is
they say I wonder if he's gonna get
jealous and [ __ ] you know you did but
yeah you would bump me in the doors and
my head would hit doorknobs and [ __ ] it
was funny you didn't make it it wasn't a
joke to you though you would knock me my
body knock me body and I would slam my
head into the doorknob because that's
how how tall I was yeah so I good on me
for realizing your height and no knowing
that the doorknob would Rico your hair
no company shoots a thing but I will
tell you what I would do what well one
thing that made me laugh so hard when
you were running around and we'll get to
the episode but we're having a lot of
good time bullshitting I would take the
big pillows off the couch Wing them at
your head oh just the right weight that
you would hit and then try to catch her
and and you'd be walking like six steps
and then fall down dude I would be cool
how old was I I don't know man I
remember you talking about that but I
don't remember doing it four okay three
so that probably added about two or
three years of therapy to my life that's
cool uh all right cool well let's get
into the thing uh feeling good we're
having a good time
beautiful hair I love the show quick
question for you so friends and family
are always asking to hang out always
asking to do stuff constantly so popular
I don't want to do that [ __ ] I got my
own stuff I like to do yeah Steve
Buscemi I just need your opinion what's
the best way to not uh the way he's
talking seemed like a dick when I'm
telling him no because right now uh s
I'm a dick yeah yeah Steve Buscemi wow
Stephen that's what I was saying tell
them you're on set making a movie
because you're Steve Buscemi yeah be
like sorry I'm busy being young Steve
Buscemi
um he for sure is uh that's a spin move
mentality for sure thing no
no but I don't think I don't think
you're being a dick you're not being a
dick because I'm like that too I don't
know be a person be a person
be a person that your family and friends
your loved ones know yeah and by being
that person that they know
be the kind of person that they don't
even ask so you know I remember when you
guys would have game night
and you guys texted hey you coming to
game night and the group chat and I was
like I never asked you no no him and I
was like what the [ __ ] well you guys are
already talking about it's like what are
you talking about we have game night I
really for how long years I had no idea
because my friends [ __ ] know me and
that made me so happy that you didn't
invite me to that [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever you were playing parchesia or
who cares the other thing is we didn't
want you to come you did no so that was
our other I don't know if that's true
man
um
yeah no I just think you need to you're
you need to get it out of your head that
you're being a dick yeah and and just
because someone thinks you're a dick
doesn't mean that you are oh man preach
people will call you a dick for a lot of
reasons in fact one of those reasons is
you don't do what they want you to
preach okay stop it but it but you know
uh enjoy just keep that in mind when
people call you a dick you're unless
you're being a dick this sounds really
stupid but it's true if you think about
it or it's it's insightful if you think
about it you're not a dick if you're not
being a dick you can be a dick
and then everyone knows you're a dick
poetry yeah but
if someone doesn't get what they want
from you
and they think it'll be fun and you say
I don't want to do it they're going to
call you a dick but they're not right
yeah let's put a bunch of marshmallows
in our mouths I mean no one suggested so
you say no no dick yeah I want to I
don't I don't I don't know but it's
about boundaries dude set your
boundaries man be like you know what I
don't want to hang out and it's all good
love you don't don't pressure me right
but don't you could just say that all
the first part you don't say it don't
pressure of course not but if they do
then you'll be like don't if they're
like come on be like nah I don't want to
you make me feel bad I don't like that
oh block okay we don't need to do
anything just say no thanks love you
we'll hang out some other time but
here's what I think honestly if somebody
says come on man it'll be fun you go you
write one month and they say what's that
and you say that's the amount that now
we are not talking no that's your huge
dick I mean I think it would be fun two
months I want to add more are you
telling him how to be a dick
or no because here's the thing you need
to respond accordingly if someone's like
ah but come on we're all going and
[ __ ] this and that one month
congratulations would you like to add
more no that's not good but I just
because that person is not trying to be
a dick and Ron really wants you to come
two months would you like to add more no
no that's so bad
I think that you just need to know
you're not a dick yeah you're not and
then that seem like he might be a dick
honestly at the end I was like he's he's
maybe a day yeah yeah because Steve
Buscemi is good at playing [ __ ] yep
so it kind of influenced my thinking yep
there we go yeah that's much better okay
I got it okay cool it's like the halo
effect but just the bishop effect
worst effect let's do another one
what's up Chris what's up man an
amalgamation of every guy I know here's
what's going on I just moved in Northern
Utah and I'm having a hard time dating
here
because a lot of the girls up here are
Mormon and I am not Mormon so I met a
girl the other day at a party
Thanksgiving party dry party you know
there's some crazy going on but she was
super cute super down to earth super
likable but she has this affiliation
with the Mormon church
I have a hard time understanding if I
should conform to that to be with this
girl you know I mean what so let me know
what you guys think about that
informing to another person's beliefs to
to date them thanks uh it's I mean
absolutely not
what what that is the longest foot Val
Kilmer in the Saint you need to start
dating the person and then once you
realize oh this could really work then
you consider that you don't consider
that before date one yeah so backwards
and if she wants you to consider that
before day one then she's crazy hey
you're cute want to be Mormon yeah oh
yeah it doesn't work like that I don't
know who put it in this guy's head
that well you should think like that or
that it's okay to think like that the
Mormons but that's okay stop but that's
completely abnormal yeah to think that
way and to be ex he's saying it like
it's totally normal yeah because they're
brainwashing him and that's the [ __ ]
thing over there he lives in Provo or
some [ __ ] and they're like well you know
I mean look you don't have to be but
it's great look at how friendly we are
look at the chicks they got More Bounce
to the ouch did you like some turkey by
the way want to be Mormon put these
underpants on and come into our church
didn't someone try to make you Mormon
once dude many times no like they showed
you a video and everything right yes oh
really yes many times what do you mean
many times I let them have at it how
many times have you been courted by the
Mormon so many times I'm not even
bullshitting man oh yeah I guess you
have I've dated many Mormons yeah and
they all try to convert me dude and I've
I've been friends with many Mormons
because I don't judge yeah right yeah
obviously
and so when I was friends with the
Mormons they'd be like why don't you
watch this video I watched the video
it's the worst movie of all time I'm
like okay not just friends with Partners
what friends dude friends and I gave it
a good college try I was like look all
right maybe it'll be good because I'm Mr
open-minded right so wait how many times
have they put the whole croissant press
on you the full court press yeah maybe
twice a full court okay but the the like
a half court kind of yeah yeah yeah zone
defense 12. what yeah yep all same
person different times no different
people some different some different
times yep the one time I got into deep
trouble with a Mormon kid that I was
friends with uh
it was in high school and I told them
that he he looked Mormon and he got
really mad about his morning yeah cool
and he got really mad and I in
retrospect I realized understandably he
got mad because I was like profiling him
and his people but well at the time
blonde and fair-skinned yes okay at the
time he was like what do you mean I look
more I was like
well I don't know like use his name
Brigham you look Mormon no his name was
fun okay well done you look more
mentally and he said
he got kept getting more and more mad
he's like what is that supposed to mean
was that supposed to mean I was like
what do Mormons look like and I was like
you yeah dude look at that hey dude go
in the bathroom and look above the sink
yeah yeah uh I realized my the error in
my way is in retrospect but at the time
I was like they look like you because
every moment I've met looks like you
profiling is profiling because profiling
is a thing and sometimes you can just
kind of yeah I mean it's like a cliche
sometimes a cliche yeah I'm in Provo and
they look at all these blonde hair guys
well we're obviously not in the [ __ ]
uh Village of the Damned these are
Mormons yeah right yeah yeah yeah so and
it's okay but you know profile away
sometimes profile profile me I don't
give a [ __ ] right yeah but the argument
would be that that's your privilege
speaking oh right the argument would be
that yeah the argument from Cox okay
well
right going downhill fast yeah but it's
fine dude so what I'm saying is
um
uh
doesn't even know what he's saying
change don't change your [ __ ]
religion because you saw someone yeah
yeah at a party do it you felt good with
the [ __ ] you know what I mean like oh
this is all right you know you know he
in his head he's like
haven't doing those he's a mouse
oh wow and then someone came so high
pitched the reasoning what's up oh hey
what's up oh hey we're hitting it off
they're probably not even hitting it off
he just thinks he is she's probably like
well I would never hang out with this
civilian do you think she actually said
yeah I think he's making it all up
making it all up yeah she didn't do that
he's got the face of a guy he does he's
got a face that looks like every guy and
everyone's ever met all put together my
point is just meet her maybe hang out
with her have a coffee with her you
can't right because they don't turn
caffeine but go to have berries with her
somewhere and then you know feel it out
if you like it and be like hey let's
hang out again and she's like I don't
know because and then be like look I'm
kind of open-minded you know maybe you
have that video that crystallia saw you
know I guess it wouldn't be a VHS
anymore is a long time what was it was
it the same thing something called like
God's Army it wasn't that but something
like that was it the same one that they
showed you but there was a recruitment
video no it was a movie that was
supposed to be it was like something
that you know it was like something like
one of the first tapes that they would
have burned if there was a revolution
because like oh we can't have propaganda
wow yeah okay but it was the same one
what does that mean
I'll tell you what it means okay even
though it's utterly obvious with it the
same one it happened 12 times to you oh
the full core press is different thing
they didn't know so the two times two
full core presses the same video no they
showed me one time they showed me a
video and then they showed you
Cliffhanger sat me down and talked to me
oh no video
in a church no video no video they just
did like a play version of it
wow dude in the church huh in the church
dude
they let you in and you can go in the
church you can't go in the you can't go
in like the temples where the party's at
you can go in the church you can't go in
the temples what's the difference the
temples are like where you get married
and they're very sacred the church is
like where you can go and people can get
recruited
um I didn't know there was a difference
yep God Mormons huh well no all of the
religions what what does that mean
they're just insane dude yeah but some
are more insane yeah well some are more
insane than others okay but like you
know you gotta if you're gonna say
Mormonism You Gotta Throw Catholicism in
there yeah I mean I've talked plenty of
[ __ ] about Catholicism but we're not
talking about Catholics I'm just saying
don't single them out and also but he
did I know but I'm saying I don't want
it to seem like we're coming for that
ass for them no it's every religious
person and I'll go further anybody who's
too into anything I come for that it's
actually not even the people who are
religious it's the religions themselves
100 how they make people think Mormons
are the [ __ ] okay it's such a 180 no
okay Mormons are the [ __ ] they are the
[ __ ]
oh bro I've known are you kidding me but
I'm saying based on the ones that have
tried to convert you you've known at
least 14. Mormons are the coolest dude
some some of them they won't let you
swear you know but like that sucks
obviously because I'm gonna do me
regardless because here's the thing
though I'm gonna do me regardless right
um yeah so sometimes they won't let you
do you regardless but I'll do me
regardless and then they gotta walk away
with their wife they're gonna do [ __ ]
black ties all right cool let's go to
another one see ya Matt Matt left guys
let's take a break I want to talk to you
about a little thing called ship station
shouldn't say little it's a big thing uh
and in a landscape where free and fast
shipping is in the norm it can be harder
for smaller e-commerce businesses to
compete keep yourself competitive with
ship station I do when you use ship
station you can lower shipping costs
make returns easy and keep your
customers happy and with all the time
you save from automating automating your
shipping tasks you can keep your
business growing all year long ship
station makes it easy to grow your
business by handling your orders from
every Marketplace in One dashboard you
understand that effortless effortlessly
ship station integrates everywhere you
sell online Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and
more
manage every order from one simple
dashboard
automate routine shipping test you can
print the shipping labels uh you can
pair rates it's so easy optimize every
shipment it's just awesome to deliver
notifications to galore uh with the best
discounts in the industry you'll never
worry about overpaying or shipping get
up to 84 off USPS and UPS rates and if
that's not enough use our promo code to
try ship station free for two months
that's over and guess what you don't
know how many companies 130 000
companies dude I'm not lying
they've grown their e-commerce
businesses with ship station and 98 of
the companies that stick with ship
station for a year become customers
that's it
keep growing your business all year long
with ship station use promo code
Lifeline today at shipstation.com to
sign up for your free 60-day trial it's
two months that's shipstation.com promo
code Lifeline the NFL playoff action
continues I don't know if you're
watching but I sure am We Are One Step
Closer to Super Bowl 57 and for the NFL
divisional round check out DraftKings
Sportsbook and official sports betting
partner of the NFL new customers can bet
just five dollars what does that mean
they get like six bucks back or
something like that 200 in free bets
instantly what plus all new and existing
customers can take a shot at an even
bigger payout with DraftKings stepped up
same same game yeah I've heard about
this those are those are really really
really uh gangbusters stepped up game
same game parlays
boost your NFL winnings with each leg
you add up to 100 who do you have what
do you got going on who do you think is
going to win and who's your money on
going all the way this year I got my boy
patma Holmes pat pat on the Chiefs which
you probably didn't know I did but he's
in the Chiefs but for for tonight's game
yeah the NFC game wild card game
Cowboys
against Cowboys and Prescott Monday yeah
all right okay okay so sue me all right
okay
Cowboys
against Mr Tom Brady Invincible right
Buccaneers Buccaneers have a terrible
record it's going to be the Cowboys Dak
Prescott
I'm I'm I'm That's My Boy deck press out
I like him he came to my show oh because
he likes you that's how you work yeah
you like people who like you okay uh
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use code Lifeline that's what's up
new customers can bet five dollars on
the NFL divisional round and get not
just a little bit but 200 in free bets
instantly only at DraftKings Sportsbook
with code Lifeline minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for details another one hi Matt
and Chris all right a poet what a pretty
serious question to ask him I believe
you um is it still cool to listen to
Jamiroquai yeah and have you heard his
song Lifeline because I think it's a
banger thanks really uh the the first
part is absolutely it's still cool to
listen to mirror well it'll never not be
cool to listen to jamiroquence Insanity
what's that one because that's the song
famous video what's his name Glazer did
what uh the guy that directed uh sexy
beast
why can't I remember his first name
Glazer yeah because you're not a [ __ ]
huge dork Jonathan Glazer dork
um so yeah dude I mean like it's a good
uh it's it's a good it's a good song but
that what other song does he have dude
how do you know any of jamiroquy's other
songs jamiroquy
um oh excuse me dude Jamiroquai was
[ __ ] huge dude for [ __ ] 15 minutes
he had a hat that was a piece anybody
that puts on that hat what do you think
of Jamiroquai but show it show it on the
thing so everyone knows because I'll
tell you right now about 90 of the
people on this listen I don't know who
jamiro come on dude I'm telling you man
Virtual Insanity
the hat and that's why because look at
his hair dude I want the left I want the
one on the hair no that's when the Hat
melts
he looks like Josh Hartnett
dude Batman villain a Batman is he
appropriating Native American culture oh
look at that now that's good
appropriating cowboy culture wow
dude have you ever heard the [ __ ] uh
the guy who goes
wait do the one with the
next to him yeah
dude I don't like guys no the headline
is no Jamiroquai did not take part in
the Pro Shop but no I thought that was
Jamiroquai dude you know what I don't
like is when guys who do singing and
stuff do singing singers is the RR are
making it because of any other reason
than they're [ __ ] killer singers like
don't put the Hat on dude I'd be about
that music but he is about that music
that that song is Amazing okay fine but
I don't know the new the new Lifeline
song
Nobody Does people only know Virtual
Insanity
how many how many uh views does it have
I mean 80 gajillion 216 million oh
that's not enough
it should be one of the most viewed
that's what I'm saying on 1996.
that is a ton yeah
um look at that set that's cool man it
is a really cool set it's very obvious
how they did it
I don't like that way of thinking though
I know how they do that yeah but I know
it but it's fine but I know how they did
that up there goes the bird do you see
the Family Guy thing I'm in high school
no it's funny anyway
um all right cool so yeah I think it's
final dude listen what you listen to
Listen to Jamiroquai listen to Matisyahu
listen to [ __ ] zap More Bounce to the
Ounce
wow
a nursery rhyme
all right
all right next one Chris and Matt good
morning from Queensland Australia very
cool uh I need some advice
my ex-girlfriend of four and a half
years he killed her
Circle as me
um and I'm seeing this girl I've been
seeing her for almost a year now
um and every time we hang out with my
friends my ex is there yeah it's gotten
to the point where we're going out for
dinners
um New Year's Eve party just gone she
was there
um
where
we're going camping
um I don't really mind it I said to my
partner that it's you know
um it's so each other here and all there
whether she's around or not it doesn't
yeah of course it doesn't bother you
know he's not moving um my partner
doesn't like it but she's kind of just
you know she's she's expressed her
feelings and she's kind of playing it
cool
um okay there's been no awkwardness or
anything but I'm just not really sure
how to navigate it I don't want to push
my mates aside
um
because then you know they're pretty
much the animates I've got I was hoping
um so yeah I'm not really sure what to
do it helps out that'd be awesome thanks
fellas love your podcast thanks bud do
it seapod on wasn't going anywhere
better buckle up gotta do these videos
he's ready he was getting he's getting
ready yeah dude uh we why don't you take
this one man uh who cares yeah okay 100
who cares who cares no one cares your
girl's not mad you're not mad obviously
your ex isn't mad such a non thing she's
look if she's creating problems and like
picking fights she doesn't you cut me
off and I didn't like that and I didn't
like that but you didn't he said but uh
there's no I I didn't hear a problem so
therefore there is no problem because if
there was a problem I would have heard
it yeah I am calling the lifeline needs
some advice
um my neighbor walks the dog so like
what do I do
hi what's going on
um yeah I've got some advice I need some
advice here I drink water uh let me know
hey what Lifeline what's going on I got
need some advice ah
love the port thanks a lot so wait okay
so I there's a number of ways it could
be a problem yeah so let's maybe assume
that he left that part out or something
I guess dude but he didn't he
specifically said it wasn't a problem
yeah he did yeah I need some advice
don't have a problem
that's so weird dude I think his current
girlfriend kind of has a problem and
she's she does you know why woman no no
no dudes would have a problem come on
dudes would but they wouldn't have a
caddy problem dudes would be like what's
up and they would end that [ __ ] no no oh
dude dude it's hard to have a problem
and then it would just be a different
kind of problem yeah exactly but it
wouldn't stop they wouldn't put a crush
on it because you understand that you
can't bring the dude around anymore and
the dude's being a [ __ ] about it the
chick is like oh hi oh nice purse ooh oh
you can get oh yeah no I've seen plenty
of people with that purse
no it's
oh I know you agree with me dude guys
are definitely just as Petty as girls
about this kind of [ __ ] Petty bro they
do fisticuffs what the [ __ ] what
physically they do fisticuffs on each
other no they don't what is fisticuffs
fighting
it's that's what that means yeah okay
what are those things when you put your
fingers Chinese butt finger traps oh you
can put your DNA too but that's oh my
God
I guess you could put your a lot of
things it has to be hard and then you
and then you're looking at each other
and you go come on no no no no and then
it rubs and you go
you know what I mean come right on each
other
on each other each other we're gonna
have to bleep a lot of that out on each
other's comes so far okay
um but yeah no don't move we'll come
we're both not gay let's just breathe
but I gotta go get soft and hug each
other and then we'll be able to walk
with me
you like that you know uh okay wait wait
um
[Laughter]
I already forgot completely what we're
talking about it's all good though dude
why why are they Jewish dick because the
Chinese is trying to get it because
they're not circumcised dude [ __ ] in
they are circumcised because they're
because they're circumcised it's easier
for them but please please do oi please
great now I'm Kanye okay oi look oh yeah
I thought you're doing a [ __ ]
Australian accent
oh god oh no we're trapped wow don't do
that don't do that do Australian make it
an Australian thing or why because it's
like boy yeah oh nice
yeah dying
everything has an A in it all right cool
next one
there's no problem no problem you're
good the [ __ ] so so cool uh always make
me laugh quick uh friendship advice me
and my family recently in a fire I'll
fire oh God uh we've ever nearly died
she's been uh obviously physically and
emotionally
draining
and damaging yeah none of my friends
have messaged I've rang none of them
give a [ __ ] come on yeah one of them
reached out and said hope you're all
right uh
so what should I do should I
speak should I confront them should I
tell them your [ __ ] friends yes or
should I just leave walk away never
speak somewhere no no no it's clear that
they don't give a [ __ ] about me or my
family
uh Sarah just your advice please but
thanks again for everything you do in
the show make me laugh when I feel like
I can't laugh keep doing what you're
doing thanks buddy appreciate it oh yeah
dude thank God you made it out dude
here's the thing
when somebody goes through something bad
and you're sitting there thinking should
I text them or should I not I don't want
to bother them
text them you [ __ ] yep just you're not
gonna bother them what even what even is
that dude I [ __ ] house caught on fire
the guy almost burned it
alive with his family inside their home
text him and just be like hey I heard
you heard you almost burned alive with
your family inside your family home yeah
everything cool heard about the house
and the family suck but I think it's a
cop-out to even be like I don't want to
bother them I don't even think that's
the real people are let me just tell you
man people are really [ __ ] shitty but
like they they I know a guy through a
guy that was dying of cancer and
everyone just kind of stops talking to
him because they were like I don't know
how to deal with it yeah yeah but I
don't think that that's shitty though I
think that that's like a glitch in the
system because they're not these people
do care his friends do care about it
yeah right but he's sitting there
thinking they don't that's why it's
shitty but they're not being shitty I
don't think I mean their nature is not
shitty they're just they're like
uncomfortable with grief or pain or yeah
or anything like yeah they're not
thinking like I'm not gonna write him
because I don't want him to feel good
but they are thinking uh maybe I should
say something I don't want to make it
worse maybe yes which is just yeah not
right that's stupid just don't make
complicated text them hey thinking of
you period yeah send and if the end and
if they don't text you you text them hey
I was in a fire dot dot dot question
mark LOL
dude I think that you honestly uh need
to send them this video
and don't even tell them your part send
them our part just just clip out our
part send our part and then they'll be
like don't know oh I know who's talking
to okay
you could also call him out well you
yeah I mean if you want to keep up
friendship be like yo bro I was in a
fire what's the what the [ __ ] yeah but
don't uh don't assume they don't give a
[ __ ] about you that that's wrong there
you go dude and that's why Matt does the
one-on-one sessions and I don't that's
that's not even right but they do
they're just awkward stupid [ __ ]
humans yeah they're over complicating
things for no reason and that's why you
do you but then again also I'll be in
Portland right and I'll be in Seattle
but you do very different things I know
I know you do you and you give good
advices but also for me dude I will be
in New York February 18th okay plugging
yourself so hard okay I'm making it
about you at the very end okay all right
well good luck to you man that [ __ ]
sucks a lot if I had your number I knew
you at all I would test you why don't
you leave uh condolences in the comments
forum a guy in the fire sorry to hear it
yep all right yeah
hey man Chris Miss Keith gonna kick our
asses a long time listening
hey hey guy not Chris it's Keith heard
what you said about me
at the schoolyard uh after school at 3
30. uh I'm gonna hand you your [ __ ]
ass thanks
Justin Verlander I appreciate you
on New Year's I mean my fiance had a get
together with both of our families it
was nice time
me and the father started bickering oh
he told me he'd stop using profanity
um you know don't worry about everything
behind this my house there we go uh
suddenly hit me when I wasn't looking
scuffled for a little bit
um it got broken up there's a lot of
people and then I hear he's bleeding
he's bleeding so I rushed to the front
and my fiance's father stabbed my best
friend in the throat
rushed to the hospital died twice thank
God he made it he's hurt but he made it
uh my question is do you ever see us
being able to have a normal relationship
again after this that's our father um
her fiance the father of a child
she has nothing no consequences
whatsoever for her obviously she had
nothing to do with it but just no
normality I don't know if things can go
back I don't know if I could ever be in
the same room as the sky you're trying
to kill your friend so I don't bail
because the wedding I don't I don't know
just because you try to let me know
thanks so much okay so here's that you
can never and should never ever no
associate with that man again and your
fiancee should also do that but if she
doesn't because it's her dad she does
need to understand that you will never
do that yeah so here's here's the
question just to break it down what the
[ __ ] that's unbelievable Dude Looks Like
Halloween this is [ __ ] unbelievable
thanks for taking the picture by the way
this is to be clear
this is the question that you asked I'm
gonna just break it down okay to the
question you asked okay hey
someone stabbed my best friend in my
house
should I rekindle
the answer is no it was his ass yeah it
was his house his house yes
don't swear you guys like don't worry
about it it's my house
oh [ __ ] oh
just stabbed it I miss her I thought he
said hey it's my house don't swear here
no dude
oh that's right
Chris is right okay we had it yeah
you're right yeah yeah hey I didn't know
that dude his house hey
[ __ ] hey don't say that well it's my
house well dude pop oh [ __ ] get him off
where's your friend
[Laughter]
why did he stab his friend the guy
didn't even die once he died twice
the guy said he died twice you had one
guy twice he's like should I rekindle
man should I work it out should we open
up a business uh think about opening up
a pizzeria with the guy no knives but
you know
dude hey hey as a matter of fact break
up dude get up come on but also you got
to have a serious talk with you lady
yeah yeah yeah you do yeah hey so about
your uh dad that's that stab my friend I
tried to kill my that killed my friend
actually came back he died twice uh but
do I get extra Dome or like wait why the
[ __ ] did he stab the friend let's make
up for it dude who the [ __ ] knows who
cared doesn't matter you know well the
friend was probably like hey
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah stop
punching my friend inside the house dude
but wait what the [ __ ] this guy is got
gray hair this this guy's like gotta be
in his mid-30s right yeah so the dad's
like just some 70 year old guys stabbing
people in other people's house
absolutely insane
that guy
the dad I hate to say it needs to be
locked up yeah lock him up
oh oh
bro bro look at this scar
you stabbed him in the neck he's just
that straight up attempted murder player
you're not gonna play it
I mean
you're talk you're literally talking
about attempted murder you are actually
just full stop
you you are discussing attempted murder
like that is an attempted murder while
this podcast is [ __ ] good today wow
wow I mean the guy [ __ ] stabbed the
guy looks like [ __ ] why so serious
he's never gonna look [ __ ] the same
ever again I mean that'll go down a lot
it'll go down a lot he will never look
the same but this kind of thing makes
he's gonna be fine okay but you're doing
a thing that I don't like which is
making it a minute apples and oranges no
you're not just minimizing determine a
different thing he'll wet it up for sure
but no one wants to look no one wants to
look totally different for the rest of
their life when it wasn't up to them I
was
what's up what's your name oh this yeah
I got stabbed at my friend's house died
twice Yeah by his fiance's dad opened up
a pizza parlor together
yeah that that's absolutely insane dude
that is insane so update Us by the way
on scone on with dad also hey Dad send
in a video Hey Dad turn yourself in yeah
because you committed a crime well I
mean no yeah so much evidence I mean
just so you don't need to turn yourself
in the game you don't need to do it you
don't need to interview anybody all you
need is cops watch this episode he's on
bail he said that's what happened Dad is
on bail that is in jail for what he did
and he's out on bail yes okay wow
assault with a deadly weapon or
something like that whatever wow dude
I mean all right
although but honestly though hey guy
just to wrap this up yeah
that you're even thinking about it is I
don't know what's going on in your mind
you can't associate with this [ __ ]
guy anymore yeah I'm not clear if he was
talking about how should I
deal with the father Yes because just
don't yeah he was okay I thought maybe
there was how should I deal with the
relationship he was saying that's fine
that's when he was like doing this [ __ ]
he was like that's not even a thing she
had nothing to do with it and ah okay oh
yeah yeah but that he's right about that
she's obviously you cannot and should
not ever thank God the guy's still alive
put any blame I mean
wow but also you're 70. get over the
desire to stab people when you disagree
with that doesn't matter how old he is
you know it's like don't well dude if
you're [ __ ] 25 it makes more sense
and if you're 70. stabbing your [ __ ]
daughter's friends in the neck
all right
that's fun
hey so cute I've been listening to you
guys you guys for forever I'm a little
in love with both of you but it's
probably fine I'm here with Ollie my son
he's 11 years old he loves Roblox and
soccer and he rocks this sweet hair look
at that hair on Ollie our question is
about the hair when we go out oftentimes
Ollie gets mistaken for a girl
and uh it doesn't really bother him he's
actually kind of amused uh when people
are embarrassed when they realize he's a
good looking dude so I got it we're
hoping you guys can help us come up with
like a quick witty response
um nothing hurtful obviously but just
something yeah kind of smart and funny
right to help people right
um just know that he's a dude yeah yeah
some sweet long hair yeah thanks
well before the curse comes up with the
retort I it well I used to have really
really long hair like way way longer
than it is now I lived in New York and I
was a hypochondriac and I used to always
go to the Health Center in New York and
the way that it was situated was my you
there were two places to sit sometimes
you'd have to sit in the area where your
back was to where the nurse comes out
and calls your name and the nurse I kept
hearing the door open and close open and
closed and I was the only one in the
waiting room and I was sitting with my
back to her the nurse and I kept hearing
her come out and like maybe about to
call my name and I was getting excited
and then she didn't call my name finally
one time I looked back
and her face was like oh because she
just assumed that I was a woman
because of my long hair and she was so
embarrassed that I felt bad that she did
it in the first place
I wasn't insulted because like Ollie I
don't really I I don't take it personal
that someone thought I was a woman just
because I had long hair from the back
but on my experience the person already
feels so dumb for thinking that out that
you're not what you really are that you
may not need
just a little push is what I'm
recommending you don't want to like body
slam them because they probably already
feel pretty stupid for getting it wrong
in the first place especially for Ollie
he's young and like you don't want to
yeah insult a kid yeah ever you know
yeah unless it's an adult that thinks
he's a girl yeah but and then you feel
even worse no you go like this you just
like oh are you a girl be like nah but
your mama is and I just hung out with
her wow
[Music]
the whole time I thought you were being
rude and texting on your phone you were
just getting ready to do that while you
weren't even listening to my story
that's cool are you a girl nah but are
you a girl no but your mama is and I
hung out with her last night
why are you putting your hair up yeah
you're just doing this with a yeah yeah
now I'm pissed at you
because you weren't even listening you a
girl nah I'm a dude why you you want me
to be a girl what are you gay
I mean that is the dumbest
yeah don't do any sex jokes do one
that's not a sex joke okay um you girl
oh yeah yeah like because he's okay so
your girl uh hey what's up girl
um
hey you might want to fix your eyesight
yeah
nice
yeah
um okay why because I got long hit why
because I got long long hair what is
this 1942 yeah that's good yeah
yeah okay okay showing you yeah okay you
got another one I don't know go ahead
you know just like more
hey dude
no
not for anything just everything else
aside though I think Ollie's hair was
double in fact I was seeing it in the
image I was like wait is that his hair
like off the side I was like I hope that
I thought literally they were behind a
horse yeah it was beautiful draped over
his shoulder because that's how ill it
was that was beautiful hair uh
definitely don't cut it you look really
cool you look cool as [ __ ] and you and
you could be a headbanger you could do
like and do like that kind of he could
be in a band but also it's you know 2023
you could be a you could be a doctor
with that hair who cares right yeah
uh it's 20 23 I could be I could grow up
be a doctor with this hair
that would be a good comeback yeah
all right
okay wow okay
hey man Chris how's it going to be
synchronize this podcast you guys indeed
rip hell yeah so I'm calling to you know
ask you guys
right now my wife and I were having our
first kid to 37 years old and we're
about 27 weeks into this pregnancy
you're gonna ever have been at this
point so are we and amazing you know due
to you know us having a lot of pregnancy
losses
um no I'm fighting I'm having a hard
time trying to enjoy this process of it
um and my wife you know is you know
trying to find that joy in it also and
you know I'm just sort of you know in
the back of my mind always thinking that
you know what if you know things are
good now but what if they aren't later
and and I was just wondering if you guys
had any advice on how to sort of open up
my my heart to enjoying this letting the
walls down and everything anyway have a
good one guys bye let me say something
before you go because you can speak to
it a bit more than I can but all I I
think is that first of all at 27 weeks
you're pretty close to viability so like
you're getting really close so it's like
it's like eight out of ten if it was if
if something happened you were and you
and the baby was born now it's like
eight or nine out of ten chance that it
would survive there you go so that's one
but two I would say don't
what you're describing and the
difficulty you're having and joining the
process is
so beyond understandable that I don't
think you should judge yourself for not
be not like being able to enjoy this
part of the experience just be the way
that you are feel the feelings that
you're feeling and then when the baby is
born then you will just be over the moon
you will be enjoying it you won't have
to worry about uh what's gonna happen
this what's gonna happen that it'll be a
whole series of other worries but in
terms of your specific trauma you're not
going to have to worry about that
anymore so the end is near the the light
is at the end of the tunnel don't be
hard on yourself feel whatever you're
feeling it's fraught it's scary it's
exciting it's a lot of different things
but don't don't be hard on yourself for
not being able to quote enjoy it right
now it's totally understandable that you
are having a hard time doing that yeah I
feel for you dude I hear that you're
scared and I think that it's okay I
think that you should be I think that
you know you're working with a little
bit of PTSD because it happened and
that's totally normal
um I I I'm I'm scared also and I I we've
never really had that kind of an issue
but um you know it's it's a it's a tough
thing anyway I think that I think that
just being open and honest with yourself
dude because this is something that I
struggle with sometimes I don't even
know what I'm feeling I just think I'm
angry and
um and and the fact that you're like you
know what this has happened before I
have fear and that's okay live through
it dude talk about it with your wife and
she'll understand you guys will both
have that connection together and then
you'll be able to work through it the
good news is you're at week 27 and um
like I said you've got an eight or nine
in ten chance that the baby will survive
if there is pre-term labor and like a
one in eight chance that the baby will
have a serious issue so those odds are
pretty good each week that moves on I
mean those are amazing odds if that's
yeah and also I'm very knowledgeable
about this stuff right I doubt it but
you don't sound like you're that far off
to be honest so uh I actually you know
that that's the truth so
so yeah dude everything you're feeling
is natural everything you're feeling is
natural anyway besides the fact that
everything that happened to you the PSD
of it
um you're gonna be okay it took those
things to get here and you're scared bro
and also I am too I'm 27 we're 27 weeks
in as well and I I have fear about it
too I'm scared of everything anyway okay
no not I mean you know what I mean no
you just said you just admitted it I
know it's not that I'm a [ __ ] you said
you're scared of everything I'm fuzzy
but it's just it's life is scary life is
real and that's okay here's the other
thing dude
you can be fearful but don't be don't
beat yourself up for being fearful
because I do that and that's making it
doubly worse and doubly hard that's what
I'm saying let yourself be the thing
that you are without adding any kind of
judgment to it because that's only going
to make it even worse yes what you're
feeling is be perfectly understandable
don't beat yourself up about the fact
that you can't like enjoy it plus from
what I understand tell me if I'm wrong
but pregnancy is fraught and is scary
don't put pressure on yourself to feel
Joy about a time period that is often
just kind of scary it is not you know
some women love being pregnant some
women just literally cannot wait to get
that baby out of them and so you know if
she's uncomfortable and you're going
through the thing just know that there
is a light at the end of the tunnel and
you know Matt's at the end is near I
wouldn't say that because that's not the
good way to put it because you say the
end is near people think about other
things right but I would say the light
is at the end of the tunnel and when
that is what I said
[Music]
and name them zap dude um is that the
group that does that song yeah I think
it's a guy right a good example Roger oh
so zap is a guy yeah zap and Roger yeah
Roger you know really Roger staying with
Roger even though the other guy was zap
zap and then also just some guy named
Roger that I met
Roger's the guy who does that Zapp and
Todd zap and Frank
um yeah so um I feel for you bro
um and my heart goes out to you but this
is also realize that you know there is
positivity mixed in with this negativity
dude you have this is what this is
you're winning dude you're winning like
Charlie Sheen you have Charlie Charlie
winning you have a beautiful
this is a moment and you're not going to
get this moment again or maybe you have
another kid but not this one it's a
different it'll be a different kid but
you have this moment to live and this is
a beautiful thing to live through and so
soak it up man because these moments
tick by and before you know it they're
gone and man I mean Calvin's already
he's gonna be three dude and I remember
when he fit in the palm of my hand
and uh you know now he's saying the word
actually and [ __ ] yeah
so bro feel for you you got this thank
you for the submission that was really
sweet and I appreciate your
vulnerability I really appreciate
people's vulnerability when they call in
um it inspires me to be vulnerable and
I'm with you dude
um and Matt you know
not so much he's not as good a person as
I am so uh I appreciate you but that's
it that's good man uh and then we can
talk you know that's it I think we're
good on on show on on uh that was a
great episode I mean we're actually the
way I think is fine you have to take a
[ __ ] so bad no I mean I don't have to I
could
um I think I could you know I ate four
hours ago and
um I feel grumbles but I could hold it
in literally
um uh I just added Salt Lake City I just
added Milwaukee but I will also
but I will be in New York New York New
York and uh not the song and uh what is
it New York New York what's this Frank
Sinatra oh yeah New York New York how's
it going I mean you're asking me I'm not
gonna get it right New York
[Music]
start spreading my balls that's not how
it goes
New York New York that's what I was
trying to do there we go still off but
all good no it's awesome good so I'll be
there I'll be in Chicago I will be in
Seattle I got that extra show added um
I'm at another show in Springfield
Missouri because that sold out who knew
who'da thunk who'd have thunk the boys
hot and sit in Springfield
but um yeah dude I'll see you tonight
Bray improv that's what's up dude these
vagabonds
disrespectful all right uh bye go to
tour chrisley.com you want a one-on-one
session with Matt go to uh
mattelier.delia.com and if you got a
question go click the link in the
description below also dude leave a
comment for that ass how do you like the
new uh thing super good we don't care
that's what we want that's it so it
doesn't matter so I'm not insecure uh
and the lifeline merch lifelinemirch.com
dude New York New York dude I'll tell
you what
play New York so you know how to sing it
why did we get up
[Music]